hello everyone
welcome to this video on machine
learning roadmap 2021
ai and machine learning have been the
top burst words in 2020.
machine learning can be an interesting
career move for programmers developers
and other professionals looking for a
script in their career
over the last few years machine learning
and artificial intelligence together
have become a crucial component in many
of the world's most popular business
applications
as we approach 2021 it's a good time for
us to take a look at the machine
learning roadmap for 2021.
in this video we will discuss the basics
of machine learning and the company is
actively hiring for machine learning
roles
you will understand the skills required
to become a machine learning expert in
2021
the salary of a machine learning
engineer and how simply learn can help
you get certified in machine learning
now let's look at what machine learning
is
machine learning is an application of
artificial intelligence that allows
systems to learn from vast volumes of
data
it enables you to process analyze and
train machines using data and create
models to solve business problems
machine learning has the potential to
learn from structured semi-structured
and unstructured data
there are various supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
algorithms used to build machine
learning models
some of the most popular machine
learning algorithms are linear
regression
logistic regression support vector
machines k-nearest neighbors
k-means clustering knife base and others
now some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are microsoft
spotify google cell ericsson
oracle and walmart there are numerous
product based
service based as well as startup
companies that are hiring for machine
learning positions
now learning machine learning can
position an individual for a variety of
exciting careers in a growing number of
industries
with machine learning becoming more
widely accepted and adapted technology
let's look at the important skills you
need to know to become a machine
learning expert in 2021
first we have programming machine
learning mostly depends on algorithms
which means one should possess sound
knowledge of different programming
languages such as python and
r you should have knowledge of basic
programming concepts and understand data
structures
this will help you write better and
efficient codes you should also know
about
searching sorting and optimization
algorithms the second skill you need to
know is
mathematics and statistics statistics is
the backbone of data analytics
you should have knowledge of various
measures such as mean median variance
etc
distributions such as uniform normal
binomial poison etc
and analysis methods such as anova
manova
t-test chi-square test hypothesis
testing and others
now this is required for building and
validating models from observed data
a basic understanding of high school
mathematics will help you understand how
machine
learning algorithms work the topics
include probability linear algebra and
calculus
the third skill you need to know is
database and sql
very often machine learning tasks are
carried out using data stored in the
form of tables
that are present in database servers so
it's important to know about databases
and sql
good understanding of relational
databases and nosql databases such as
mysql
postgresql oracle database microsoft sql
server is vital to store manipulate
retrieve and handle structured data now
we have data wrangling
now there's a lot of pre-processing of
data that is needed before you start
building your machine learning model
collecting the data cleaning it
identifying the problems
asking the right questions and
formatting the data are crucial steps in
machine learning
you should have knowledge of libraries
and packages such as numpy
pandas plier deep flyer and idea to
perform data wrangling
next we have data visualization while
working on any machine learning problem
it's important to understand the data
well data visualization and exploratory
data analysis skills are very important
to show the hidden trends and insights
in a visual form
using various charts and graphs this
will help you find out unseen patterns
in the data
you need to have experience with
matplotlib c-bond plotly and ggplot
libraries
it would be an advantage to know bi
tools such as tableau and power bi
finally the most important skill is
machine learning
itself you need to learn different
machine learning techniques and
algorithms that are widely used to solve
business problems
then implement the algorithms using
python and r libraries
such as scikit-learn tensorflow garrett
and mlr
having knowledge of natural language
processing computer vision and time
series analysis would be a really good
advantage
to gain more experience in solving real
world problems you need to work on small
projects using variety of data sets
data science and machine learning
challenges such as those on github and
kegel are a great way to get exposed to
different kinds of problems and their
nuances
now talking about the salary of a
machine learning engineer
according to glassdoor in the united
states a machine learning engineer can
earn around
114 000 dollars per annum while in india
you can earn nearly 7 lakh 73 000 rupees
per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for
and the company policy now moving on to
the final section
let me tell you how simply learn can
help you start your career in machine
learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so i am on the chrome browser
let me search for simplylearn.com
and here under what you want to learn
let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category so you
can see here
there are multiple courses first let me
open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so so this is the post graduate program
in ai and machine learning which is in
collaboration with purdue university and
ibm if i scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course so we'll get
purdue alumni association membership
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment to simply launch job assist
there's 25 plus hands-on projects on gpu
enabled labs you have
450 plus hours of applied learning
capstone projects in three domains
and much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this program
and you will also get certificates
recognized by ibm
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to simply learn job
assist program so you will get
im jobs crew membership for six months
resume assistance and career monitoring
there's interview preparation and career
affairs if i scroll further
here you can see the learning path and
you will learn about python for data
science this machine learning
deep learning with tensorflow and keras
this advanced deep learning and computer
vision
you will also learn about natural
language processing that is nlp and
speech recognition
we have reinforcement learning and you
also have the opportunity to select a
few electives so we have
ibm watson for chatbots machine learning
with r there's git and github training
and two others here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning
we learn about python supervised
learning there's dance computer vision
tensorflow
there's reinforcement learning speech
recognition you will also learn about
numpy pandas and other libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if i scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on
so this is on twitter there's one on
zumato one on uber
and mercedes benz as well they are our
course
advisors so please go ahead and enroll
to this postgraduate program in ai
machine learning if you want to kick
start your career in
machine learning now the next course we
have is machine learning certification
course
if i scroll down you can see the details
of this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
hands-on exercises
you will get to work on four real-life
industry-based projects with integrated
labs
there will be dedicated mentoring
sessions from industry experts
44 hours of instructor led training with
certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression
you will also learn about support vector
machines games clustering knife pace
decision trees
random forest and you'll learn the
concepts of
bagging and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the course content
and if i scroll further now these are
the projects that you will get to work
on
and finally you will receive this
certificate once you complete the course
and with that we have come to the end of
this video on machine learning roadmap
2021
i hope this was helpful if you have any
questions then please put it in the
comments section
also if you liked the video then please
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon
to never miss an update thank you for
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here